mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
solve for real values of x in the
following equation
the quantity x minus one over x raised
to the power of one half
plus the quantity one minus one over x
raised to the power of one half is equal
to x
i thank rookvade for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we will solve this problem using some
clever substitutions
suppose the first term is equal to a and
the second term is equal to b
the equation then becomes a plus b
is equal to x
we will multiply both sides of this
equation by the quantity a minus b
the left-hand side of the equation will
then simplify to be a difference of
squares
a squared minus b squared is equal to x
multiplied by the quantity a minus b
we will then simplify the difference of
squares
a squared is equal to x minus one over x
and b squared is equal to one minus one
over x
therefore a squared minus b squared is
equal to x minus one
we will substitute that into the
equation
we will then divide both sides of this
equation by x
x minus 1 all over x is equal to a minus
b
we will flip this equation around for
convenience
we will then simplify the right hand
side of this equation
x minus 1 all over x is equal to 1 minus
1 over x
we will then add these two equations
together
notice that the b terms cancel out
so we have two a is equal to x plus one
minus one over x
we then simplify the right hand side of
the equation
notice that x minus one over x is equal
to a squared
so we then have 2a is equal to a squared
plus 1.
we can easily solve this quadratic
equation
we subtract 2a from both sides and then
we factor
we thus have the double root that a is
equal to one
we then recall that a is equal to the
quantity x minus one over x raised to
the power of one half
we can then solve this equation for x we
square both sides of the equation
and then we will multiply both sides of
this equation by x
this simplifies to be the following
quadratic equation
x squared minus 1 is equal to x
this is a standard equation that we can
solve using brahma goop this quadratic
formula
we get two roots
one is the golden ratio one plus the
square root of five all over two and the
other is the negative reciprocal of the
golden ratio 1 minus the square root of
5 over 2.
we can see if either of these roots is a
solution to the original equation
to do that we go back to the original
equation and evaluate each root
first we'll consider the negative root
we can actually see this is not going to
be a possible solution because the sum
of two square roots will be equal to x
the sum of two square roots should be a
non-negative number and here x is a
negative number
but we'll go ahead and substitute in and
we'll see that this is not a solution to
the original equation
so we can eliminate this possibility
we are left with the other possibility
of the golden ratio and we can check
this is in fact a solution to the
original equation
therefore the solution to the original
equation is the golden ratio
it's quite a divine answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you